a lot of bad things can happen to us all
but you can't sit here and play a victim
all day long because that's not gonna
that's not you're not gonna grow you're
not going you're just gonna be a salty
dog
forever um and that's not going to
help you be a better sister wife
friend business partner boss whatever it
may be
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
on episode
93 i am joined by the one and only
natalie eva marie natalie eva marie is a
wwe
superstar actress fashion designer and
model
she's currently signed to wwe
where she performs on monday night raw
under the ring name eva marie
we discuss her rise to fame with wwe
raw and total divas how she learned to
wrestle her experiences
with alcoholics anonymous and the 12
steps program overcoming physical
difficulties
joe rogan her workout routine standing
up for what you believe in
and more please hit subscribe if you
enjoy this episode
natalie eva marie welcome to my podcast
thank you thank you
i am uh you know very excited so i'm
trying to
play it cool but also let you know how
pumped i am
i'm very excited too i have a whole
bunch of questions you have accomplished
so much and i want to delve into
how you did that so awesome for anyone
for anyone who doesn't know who you are
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
yeah i think for anybody that doesn't
know i think i first made my
kind of um splash
in wwe as a professional wrestler
as well as on the reality show total
divas that's really
what kind of started uh my my career and
kind of put me
into that that space
but i also uh so i'm a professional
athlete
um and i also own
a couple businesses with my husband and
i'm also
in uh i do tv and film as well
so you can't put me in a box i'm doing
it all
yeah you're definitely doing it all so
how old were you
when you kind of got thrown into the
public eye more or less
so i was 28 when i got my first
well yes 28 when i got
they call it a diva search and basically
they don't do it anymore in wwe but what
they do is
is kind of go around to all of the large
uh cities and do kind of like a big old
cattle casting call
looking for the next wwe diva and
sure enough i was after i graduated from
college
i moved to los angeles because i was
like okay i have my business degree
but i'm not ready to go into the
business
world per se which to my parents i'm
mexican italian so
you can only imagine my parents were
like what are you doing
you're doing oh my goodness like this is
not
the route that we want you to go um
but i decided like hey i have my degree
so i have that to fall back on let me go
dabble i finished school in orange
county
uh california so i moved to los angeles
devil and a little bit of modeling and
acting and i was like oh i like this i'm
the i guess of all boys
so you know being kind of
the center of attention or trying to get
my parents attention or my other
brothers
that was like my thing so uh i fell in
love with it i really liked it but i've
been an athlete my whole life
so like i said i'm the youngest of all
boys so sports was really
important and a big thing in my life
because i wanted to be exactly like one
of my brothers
and when i finished college um
like the dream was to be a professional
soccer player
and i tore my ligaments in my ankle and
that kind of that dream
shattered that's a whole another story
but um when wwe came into town
i was like wait a minute
once i went there to the hq in los
angeles and i saw like hulk hogan and
stuff on
the walls i'm like whoa this is like wwf
like back in the day that i used to
watch
my brothers like this is crazy
then i was like wow after my first
audition because they did a couple
callbacks and stuff
i was like this could be my dream job
because not only do you have to um
perform in front of a live crowd as a
you know
working on your character but you have
to be
you have to handle the physicality
that's required to step into the ring
and have a wrestling match and then you
get to travel the world
and i wanted to do all those things i
wanted to act i wanted to perform
i wanted to travel and uh then obviously
wwe does a lot within the communities
that they
you know go around the world to so i'm
like man if i can get this job it's my
dream job so
let's give it a go and you weren't a
wrestler
you weren't a wrestler before god no no
i was a field athlete meaning i like my
feet on the floor
soccer was my sport so wrestling was
brand new i was like
had no idea i don't know what taking a
bump was
um it's it's not what people think of
like you know
drugs it's more like you take a flat
back um
in the wrestling ring didn't know how to
run ropes uh
definitely nothing whatsoever
was um in my arsenal so it was something
that you know i
was like let me give it a whirl and fell
in love with it
that's crazy so how long did it take you
to learn how to wrestle
girl so that's what's even crazier
is i mean god
puts you in a certain certain situations
and right timing i believe it you know
uh and all of that right time right
place and then all obviously seizing
that opportunity as well
so um at the same time that
my diva search was happening this was in
2013.
they were also in
talks and production pre-production of
doing a reality show
showcasing the life of a wwe diva
now they're called everyone's called
superstars but at the time when i was
there it was diva so um
i get through my audition and then a
couple callbacks callbacks
and basically i had a four week tryout
to see if you could handle the
physicality and then if you got your
if you made it through they would give
you a developmental contract which
basically all that means
is you then now move
to at the time the facility was in tampa
florida
and i always refer to it as like the
minor leagues in baseball right you have
like triple a
so you're there and you're working on
your skills
your craft you're learning how to
wrestle you're building your character
okay um and then you hope that you get
called up to the main roster which is
monday night raw or smackdown but now
nxt is almost like now it's its own
kind of huge brand because now it's
televised as well but back then it was
really really developmental
so that's what i was going for that's
what i was aiming and that's what i
ended up
getting but because i was in los angeles
they called me up and said you know what
we have this thing we can't really tell
you too much about it will you go in
for this interview audition because it
was like a green screen
you sit down and you basically are
getting hammered a million questions
like
how is it growing up what are what's
your family like this that and the other
and it was for
total divas which was the reality show
so the producer at the time told me hey
just so you know this project is moving
really really fast if you do get this
your life could change within the next
72 hours so wow i
i know i've had this couple times in my
life
this being one of them so it was a
friday i went in on my interview
i walked out being like i think i
killed that i called my now husband and
i'm like
hey i think i just smashed this out of
the park
like they said that things can move
really quickly so we jump in the car
from the bay area we drive up north and
i had just met my husband
like six weeks prior by the way and uh
we drive up to the my parents my parents
get to meet
my now husband and then he asks for my
hand
or my dad's blessing to marry me
and i get a call 24 hours later saying i
got the gig
i'm on a flight to wrestlemania on
monday
not only am i now on the main roster of
wwe which is monday night raw but i'm
also
on total divas which airs on
the e-network like that
so when it comes to learning to wrestle
it was very much so thrown into the fire
trying to learn on the road um and
that just was very difficult to do so um
you know i ended up going back to
developmental
and you see it through total divas and
stuff because i'm a perfectionist
and it was bothering me so i went back
to developmental
worked on my what does that mean what is
so basically what is developmental
it's and it's called nxt and so what
that is is like
you're off of the main roster and then
you go back and then you just like start
doing the same exact things that you
would on the main roster but
way more time like every day you're
training
on the main roster you're doing shows
because you already know how to do okay
the physicality so that's how quick and
whirlwind of it was
wow okay so this one started when you
were
it's hard to sorry so no no i apologize
because it's so hard it's so
grandiose that it's hard to
give like a one sentence answer because
it's so freaking
out of this world that even when i say
it out loud it's like
wow but that's why like god put me in uh
you know open up a door and um
you know right time right place this
episode is brought to you by grass-fed
beef
organs by ancestral supplements
ancestral supplements makes new
zealand-sourced
nose-to-tail organ meats bone marrow and
beef organs
in simple convenient gelatin capsules
traditional peoples native americans and
early ancestral healers believed that
eating the organs from a healthy animal
would strengthen and support the health
of the corresponding organ
of the individual for instance the
traditional way of treating a person
with a weak heart
was to feed the person the heart of a
healthy animal
similarly eating the kidneys of a
healthy animal was believed to support
urinary ailments and overall kidney
health
pancreas was fed to people with
digestive problems and spleen was fed to
people with immune and blood
deficiencies
our early ancestors knew this which is
why their traditional diets included the
frequent and nourishing consumption of
nose-to-tail organs
visit ancestralsupplements.com to see
what they can do for you
ancestral supplements putting back in
what the modern world has
left out and now back to eva marie so
are you the type of person that says yes
to everything
you know that is a great question
because
i feel like i am but then i'm really not
like it's such a
uh when it comes to like career and
something that i know that could be a
a major game changer then yes balls to
the wall
let's roll but if it's like hey
do you want to go out to lunch no okay
you know what i mean okay that's what i
meant i i meant i meant the game
changing like how
you know um pick up and change your life
suddenly
i i think yes because i have failed so
many times
and i have um picked myself
up and failed again so many times that
it's like that's how you
can go to the next level if you don't
take the risk then
uh it ain't gonna happen you know like i
always think to myself
if i'm just sitting on my hands i can't
i can't as much as i
believe in god in the right time and
stuff you gotta put some action behind
all of it you know you can't just
hope and pray and think that god is a
genie and grant you
these uh amazing things you know it's
like yes i believe in all of that
and the preparation and things of that
but if a big grandiose opportunity comes
then worst thing that can happen is i
don't get it but then i know that
you know i gave it a shot yep
fair enough um so on your instagram you
frequently post about alcoholics
anonymous
so my mom in the my mom had cancer
and one of the things that really helped
her cope
afterwards was joining alcoholics
anonymous and having the community
and i like i don't really know very much
about it so i wanted to talk to you
about that because
at first when she started it i was like
this is a cult
this is a cult and you're in a cult they
don't seem to take any money but it's a
cult
and um but then i've you know i've
seen what it's done for her um
and so i wanted to talk a little bit
about your experience
with them why why what what they are and
why you started uh yeah
for sure um you know it's one of those
things where
it's i i get some i don't want to say
slack but a little bit because it is
alcoholic
anonymous right um and part of that is
your whole anonymity and things of that
nature but i also
look at it in a way of being able to
share like my story like i'm not really
talking too much
i guess why they say they don't really
like people
um promoting something like that is
because
heaven forbid i were to relapse right so
then people will be like see
it doesn't work but like that's
right right yeah so that's where like
the little
issue is but i look at it is i'm not
really talking i'm just talking about
kind of my experience and i i came in
to alcoholics anonymous when i was 23.
so
um i have a family of addiction
is just like heavy in our i believe it's
in the gene
um my i never got to meet my grandfather
because he passed away from soros of the
liver
so it's just one of those things that's
just like it's like in
us um me and my family and so my oldest
brother
he actually uh you know
got into some trouble but then
once he realized
okay well maybe i should take drugs and
alcohol out of the situation then maybe
things will get better
then he got sober i always looked up to
him so at 23 my life was going
because i didn't have that sports was
always something for me
that kept me focused and kind of kept me
uh i had a goal
i was striving for something or people
were counting on me so once that was
kind of like taken
uh or i didn't have that anymore then
all of a sudden it was just like on and
popping plus a mexican italian so the
moment i
moved from my parents house and went to
college
i was like no curfew what
and not even not blaming my parents
whatsoever because i
absolutely love endure them um still
married
uh i mean um
48 years which is insane um wow yeah
uh so he told me
you know what you needed to get sober uh
because i was obviously making some
choices and and things were happening to
my life that not normal people do
you know crashing wrecking totaling cars
losing your license
going to jail those things aren't normal
behaviors so that's when you really need
to stop and be like hey
what's what's really going on so at 23 i
walked into the room's alcoholics
anonymous
i got a sponsor and started working the
12 steps
um and because i'm
human and things of that nature things
started to happen the promises in the
program they talk about
start to happen and a lot of it is all
action-based a program
of the 12 steps you know um and one
emitting your powerless over alcohol
um and i've got my license back
things were getting i got a job things
were kind of moving in the right
direction i was in a more of a healthy
relationship
and then at 26 i was like
i got this i'm fine i don't need this
program this is a cult this is crazy
i'm tired of telling people like that i
gotta go to meetings that i have to
sponsor women
that i have to check in i was just like
this is
this is just getting too much on 26
called my sponsor
told her you know what thank you so much
i love you appreciate everything you've
done but i'm good
i think i've got this i think i'm okay
like i don't advise it
um but okay you go ahead so after nine
months
of me doing you know taking back the
steering wheel
i crashed and burned and was back to
where i was and then i got sober at the
same time
i had just gotten out of rehab at the
same time that i got my
uh wwe job so thank you
jesus that i was 28 stepping into the
limelight because
with social media now and
what it's what it has became
um i would have been a huge
embarrassment to my family
early on just because i was you know
doing my own
doing my own things and being causing a
lot of destruction but i think the
program itself it gives you
it's very selfless too because part of
the 12 steps is
sponsoring other women and getting out
of your own self and giving back
to what you were uh so freely given
and it's really an honest looking at
yourself a lot of it is like your
self-inventory
um you have to do a fourth and fifth
step where it's like
you know you're looking at your part a
lot of bad things can happen to us all
but you can't sit here and play victim
all day long because that's not gonna
that's not you're not gonna grow you're
not going you're just gonna be a salty
dog
forever um and that's not going to
help you be a better sister wife
friend business partner boss whatever it
may be
so i think the program not only has it
saved my life
but this is also a huge uh
kind of plug into your whole family like
i'm a huge fan of your whole family i
love your dad
um i was a fan of you because i heard
you on joe rogan's podcast
um i mean i'm sitting here my husband
has me like reading all these like books
but
one in particular that i read last year
was your dad's
and then i got his brand new one as well
and it's funny because
when i listen to your podcast with your
dad and russell brand
one russell brand is like mind-blowing
i'm like
oh yeah mind-blowing he is so
verbally fluid he's so smart it's
incredible incredible so when you were
talking
and you were talking to your dad i was
like dude i love michaela mikayla and me
are same wavelength because i was
thinking the same thing i'm
like dude hold up my thought is still
let's bring it back a second because i'm
still stuck
on this this other phrase but um i see a
lot of
uh similarities with the 12 steps as
well as
just like the rules that your dad has
put out there because
a lot of it is cleaning up your side of
the street looking at your own self
looking at
um your part in a lot of stuff you know
and
i think that's that's really important
and plus
what the the program that's kind of how
i look at the program anything too much
of
excess is always bad you know um
too much of of aa could be very bad too
so it's like you know taking the good
and uh
and using it for your benefits so i mean
the fact that it has helped your mom
that's incredible
um that's really cool because then it's
just
she's able to be in a spot that she
could
uh relate to others and speak freely as
well as
working on the the inner self in her
dialogue
yeah it was it was confusing listening
to her for me because i was like you
don't have like she she
she never liked alcohol like i i liked i
liked alcohol
i liked alcohol a lot when i was younger
um
i knew my dad when he was younger but my
mom didn't really have that
so i was like why are you part of like
this group because it's right because of
the title
alcoholics anonymous right but then it
turns out that it's for people who have
any like almost any type of
problem i'm definitely for me i'm a
hardcore like
you know drug addict alcoholic that's
like my
my niche but people that are in there
are all walks of life
so everyone that some people have you
know
um they're going through
something other than that than alcohol
being the advice you know
um and they're and they feel right at
home in these meetings and
being in the community because it's
just really working on um
where it took me a long time to realize
like
me myself i'm when i'm making my own
decisions and taking my life into my own
hands
this is that's where things go bad
that's where things are like not
working out but when i give my you know
surrender and have a power greater than
myself
that i that i know is
working out there that's when
things go away way better let's get into
that a little bit so
when when people in this program talk
about higher power and giving themselves
to their higher power
what does that mean i know it sounds so
cuckoo
where like even saying it talking to you
i'm like yeah
no i really want to know i like i don't
even think it sounds like
it does sound like kind of like a cuckoo
cult-ish but all that means to me
is especially when i'm sponsoring other
women because a lot of people have
um an issue with god right like the
church and religion
and things of that from other how they
were raised or what they think
now um this that or the other i never
had an issue with that i was raised
catholic
um because mexican italian so it's like
you know
that's how it was but my parents were
really cool because my best friend
growing up was mormon so they
allowed me to see other types of
religion as well so that's why i don't
have any type of weirdness
when it comes to god or
or that kind of animosity or
just doesn't want anything to have a
part of it so when it comes to like
an alcoholics anonymous a power greater
than yourself all that is
is finding something that you believe
other than yourself so like some people
to me it's god i pray to god but some
people will literally just pray to like
that
something like nature
or uh the clouds or something where it's
something that is other than yourself or
like another human being that's living
um because you have to really have to
surrender
to you're not good at running the show
because if you were
you wouldn't be in this meeting you
wouldn't wound up in alcoholics
anonymous you know what i mean
so like i always say too i don't want to
do the program
i don't want to do a i don't want to
sponsor women
but i want to trade it for the world
because my life today
is beyond my wildest dreams
okay um could it be i think i've heard
my mom talk about this a bit could it
does it have anything to do with
intuition and what like
the feelings you get around you i think
my mom describes
describes her higher power as that as
like this feeling you get you know that
little voice in your head just like this
is a bad idea
like the tiny little voice or something
like that oh for sure because i feel
like when you are doing like
it it makes me feel like my intuition
is way more on point too um
because it just for whatever reason
it dials you in from like because you're
throughout the whole
kind of aaa process and stuff you're
supposed to you know have your prayers
your meditation and things like that
where you're constantly
trying to listen to that inter
intuition so you're working on it
consistently so that's a way
that's a really good way to kind of um
kind of explain sometimes that
that voice but really it's it's your
intuition or that little voice is
telling you whether or not you know
oh i don't like this person or this
doesn't feel right or maybe we do
make this move you know
interesting okay that's very interesting
okay switching switching topics a little
bit um
you seem like you're on the go all the
time and you have a lot of energy
at least that's how you come across over
over social media and
in this podcast so do you have tricks
for
i mean you're part of aaa but do you
have tricks for staying grounded
or de-stressing when you're stressed out
so i think
i think it's one of those things we all
get stressed right so like
for me i have to work out not because
it's like my profession
because now that which is kind of cool
because one of the reasons why we had to
reschedule and at the time
obviously was it wasn't public yet but
um i had to go back because now i'm back
in wwe
um i heard congratulations thank you
thank you
um but so regardless of it being like my
profession or not
for me i have to work out because it
does something
for me like it definitely makes me
more
relaxed um i also know that i have that
one check mark that i've done that i
have won for the day um that i got off
my plate number two is i've always
struggled with like body dysmorphia
and um i talked about it on like total
divas a few years back body dysmorphia
and just like
always that like never good enough and
like being like a cuckoo brain where i
would like pinch my
like just a little over excessive so
working out is is something where uh
that little voice in my head that is
like
telling me anything negative it's like
nah i smashed my workout today
that helps me de-stress because then i'm
like cool that task is done on to the
next
um i've been reading
a ton so in 2020 because
obviously 2020 was crazy for everybody
i've always wanted to be an avid reader
because my husband is and i always would
make that little goal on my
you know like new year's resolution type
goal thing and then i would never visit
it because i would never put any action
behind it so i'd always be like i want
to read more books and then
it would say i want to read more books
like nothing would ever
come about it's like hey well sweetheart
pick up a damn book
and so finally in 2020 i did it because
obviously we had a lot more time on our
hands
and uh now i find
reading is so amazing like the way
what it does is i get to go into like a
another reality you know depending on
obviously what i'm reading too
but um i feel like that has definitely
helped me de-stress as well
and kind of i think what helps me the
most
is having like the five things that are
a must
for me that need to be done so like
working out
um reading doing my prayers doing my
meditation
um and doing my program those are like
those
five things that have to get done for me
to feel like
all right well at least those are done
for the day
like you can light yourself off the hook
exactly a little bit
right so when i start not doing those
types of things
that's when it's like oh like frantic
starts to cut playing
i get really really more overwhelmed
more stressed
and then things kind of start to kind of
uh
my patience my temper how i am it starts
to diminish
so it's like having those five kind of
things that really kind of make me
um know that i can put my best foot
forward
that's kind of like what i do to make
sure like especially when things that
are so
heavy on your plate and you can't get
done for whatever reason
um then at least if i have those five
that i've done then i'm like
okay we're still okay i like that
i like that i need to i think i need to
do that more
like i have um i was i was so injured so
i couldn't do
i was very active when i was younger and
then i had surgery that just like
[ __ ] me up i cannot get over
this is why i think you are savage i
know your story i'm like that's why i'm
like a huge fan because i'm like damn
talk about perseverance determination
overcoming
massive obstacles and being just
so damn resilient that it didn't
matter and you look at you dude like
you're beautiful
you're intelligent my god
like he can't handle this it's really
cool to see
it really is i know i know it's it's
uh i don't know it's just i i love it i
think it's cool because especially
because of like all your
illnesses that you've had like people
don't know like that [ __ ] is a struggle
that is a struggle alone so yeah um
i think it's not like the light
at the other side
thank you very much i appreciate that uh
we could actually talk about a little
bit about how you
got through your ankle trouble because
you said you wanted to be a professional
soccer player and then you had that
dream
dream snatched away which has got to you
know turn your world upside down so
what happened there you know i think
it's the combination of a multiple thing
um so i tore my i tore my ligaments
my senior year of high school and i had
this like determination of like i'm
going to come back i'm going to come
back from it
better yeah during the top of my
season so that was kind of shattering
but i still had that fire in me
um that i was gonna come back and play i
did i finished the season i ended up
coming back
uh like halfway a little less than half
of the season left
and i still was able to get whatever the
little accomplishments like all-time
score whatever
and and that was fantastic but then
the belief that i put in my head started
to diminish
where and this is where i used to be
like this is such
nonsense those like self-talk
affirmations
i would always be like that like yeah
right
no way now that i'm older
now that like the 36 year old me i'm
like
wait a minute it is that stuff is super
true because not only did my body
in a sense give out on me and that was
hard but what i continue to tell myself
is really what
made me officially hang up the cleats
and that was
i kept telling myself my body hurt i
kept telling myself that i wasn't going
to be
my ankle wasn't going to withhold all of
the training and all of the stuff
required to in college um and that
weighed in on to not only my body
but also uh just my mind
and it's really difficult
to come back when your body really is
broken like when you really have
something where you're like
well i'm in a cast so i can't even walk
no matter what for at least
six to eight weeks so then you're then
you're really
uh uphill battle so for me once i
was able to you know rehab and get back
to walking then running
um then my mind was a whole another mess
so now looking yeah looking back
you know it is one of those things where
now more than ever
your mind mind body soul it's super it
has to be one or else uh
things aren't gonna things aren't going
to function and work
the way that you want them to so
um what you tell yourself and what
you're
that's why what you're reading what
you're putting what you're listening to
it is it's it's super important and it
does make a direct reflect on
to your life and and where you're kind
of either going or how you're even your
mood
um is really big because my husband
always
says uh i'm like the tasmanian devil so
if i'm like good and everything is great
we're great
everything's good good good good but
when it's not you know i can
self-destruct
in a blink of an eye and it's nobody's
fault but myself
so uh that's that's definitely
one of those things where now
i feel like i have a little bit more
because i've been through like the
trials and tribulations of
certain things how important your mind
is you know
um but yeah
i can't even i can't even sit here and
begin to even talk about any of my
surgeries or my
my issues because i'm i'm talking to the
queen right here
of multiple crazy multiple stories
yeah yeah but it's still like i don't
think it
i don't know i think that if you have
surgery then you just you have surgery
uh i've been trying to like i said i
just started working out
kind of recently again and
a lot of the problems i'm having are in
my head like it which is a great place
to have problems rather than
having them in your body it's much
better but like wow
it's amazing how scary trying to use
your body after you're injured is like
and it's amazing how much of that is in
your head
you really need somebody kind of beside
you being like okay
do it which is why physio is so
important but
i totally totally agree and that's why
like um
it gets so annoying because it's so
like your body is capable of doing way
more than what your mind thinks it is
and it's
so true i mean
two years ago i wanted to
run a half a marathon because i follow
um
cameron haynes and david goggins they
were on joe rogan's podcast as well
two savage dudes um and cam hands out
here running like 20
a goddamn marathon a day and he's
working a normal job and all this stuff
and i was like wait
what what am i doing with my life
so um i i said okay let me do this like
half marathon
thing if i can do it i've never run more
than
obviously soccer was my sport but it was
never like it just is a whole difference
thing there was
i was running towards something you know
i was training the body so that we could
win championships
not just out there on the road you know
um
running for hours i couldn't wrap my
head around
four miles to me was like this is death
this is death like how am i half a
marathon
who am i i'm no way and then i caught
the bug again
and um i was supposed to do my first
half marathon leading into 2020 and
obviously that
you know went away and then i caught the
bug and
i don't know something clicked in my
mind something completely different
where i wasn't looking at it like a
impossible task
and then i just did my first ultra
marathon in in january and i hadn't even
run up i'd want to run
a half a marathon or anything prior i
just decided like let's
let's do this so it is that's awesome
it is weird and i hate saying it because
it sounds so cliche you know it sounds
so like
just believe and it's gonna do it yeah
yeah it's like oh
god another one but
but it's kind of it is true
i that's something when i was when i was
depressed
i didn't believe any of that stuff at
all not even a little bit
and now i i really do fully think that
if you can envision
something it's like i don't want to say
manifesting
but if you can envision a future
that you want and you really i mean it's
kind of like goal setting right it's
kind of like goal setting i guess if
you're envisioning a future you want but
if you think that things are possible
that's the first step
right for achieving any type of goal
like
make yourself believe that it's possible
that well and it's that seems to work
out shockingly well
and you always end up hearing people
that actually either achieve it
or have achieved it um they say the same
thing because
i'm with you like in 20 in 2018 or 2019
i no i think it was 2017 or 2018
roughly um but i've always fluctuated
and went through bouts of like
depression right and like
being super aware
in 20 i can't remember the year but
recent where i my husband was so worried
that he like called my mom
basically being like and my mom's my
best friend i talked to her every day
where he's like you're gonna have to
come out here because
i couldn't get out of bed and looking
back on that time
it is a lot of like and even now because
we go through days
some days i'm like i'm feeling good i'll
talk to him all my brothers
i'm feeling great i feel like i can
cover the world and then some days i'm
just like
dude i'm such an ugly fat piece of
nothing like what am i doing
you know so it's like those days totally
happen
and sometimes you allow yourself i
allow myself to have maybe like 24 48
hours depending on
how severe the pity party needs to be
depending on what has happened
and then i'm like okay we're
we're moving we're doing something
because i know me
and if i stay in the wallow i'm gonna
stay there for a long
long time because i can do that too so
it is really making
your mind being like i'm not depressed
i'm getting up today i'm doing this
today like
i forced myself to do a lot of the
things
that make me feel better and that's how
what a juxtaposition that is you know
a lot of the things like some days i
don't want to work out at all i didn't
want to work out yesterday
at all my workout actually sucked but
i did it you know even if it was like
not one of my
best but i'm forcing myself to do the
things that i don't really like but i
know that they i reap the benefits
it's really so annoying how that is but
it's a it's a shitty cycle but it works
or else i'm gonna just stay in bed and
be miserable
yeah i've been having i've been having
that kind of
that kind of month where it's been like
oh man i am so on top of the world
everything's working out i just worked
you know a 14-hour day
look at everything i got done this is
great i'm on a roll and then the next
day i probably you probably get tired
when you do that too right
yeah it was just like look at all the
energy i have and then you work for 14
hours and the next day you don't feel as
hot you're probably tired
but then i'm like well where'd it go
it's gone where'd it go i was doing
so well and like now i don't want to do
anything like oh yeah
it's it's fun it's fun it's exciting
totally
it's exhausting too because it is just
one of those things
it is totally right i bet i bet you on
those days that like are
14 hours 15 hours whatever that you're
doing that you're like killing it
you're also the body and the mind is
getting tired
so i'm sure that weighs heavily into
you know the next emotions and i feel
like women
are a hell of a lot more emotional than
men so like our emotions
or at least i think so our emotions are
going to be like way more
kind of hot and cold um and so it's just
like
me learning as time goes to like you
know
control what i can control the best that
i possibly can
yeah yeah definitely okay so do you work
out every day you look like you work out
every day
well thank you um you know i
i don't work out every day but i try to
move every day if that makes sense
um i love what matthew mcconaughey said
it um
which another shout out to him because
his book was awesome it was like a fun
little story
it was good yeah it was um
he's definitely seems like a cool dude
um
i liked what he said many years ago but
like he tries to break a sweat
a day um and that's kind of kind of like
what i try to do too if i'm not really
trying to
if i'm not lifting or doing something
like
one of my programs um i'm doing like
active recovery which is just like
taking my dog for a walk or something
like that
um i try to move um and move the body
because my body now
especially as i'm getting older i feel
like the less i move it the harder it is
to start it again
yeah fair enough uh okay what are
these are some more fun questions now
that we've like gone a little bit deep
um what do you think the worst part of
fame is
i mean that's a heavy question because i
feel even honored to
not even ask because i don't really feel
like i've reached that quite yet even
though i am sitting on your podcast
um which makes me feel like i am
somebody um but
um
i would probably say or the hardest part
not the worst part the hardest part
i think i think just probably the the
basic
answer is like you're under a microscope
you know so anything you
say or do is going to get judged
but i also try to spin it in the sense
of um
i realize you're given you know i've
given a platform
and to and it's a tool so i'm in like
such a
awesome spot you know and try not to
look at such a
such a negative light which because
social media can definitely be
a dumpster for that too yeah it
definitely can you're
you're doing something uh with wwe
you're
talking you you use the term super role
model
or something like that so what are you
trying no it's cool what are you trying
to do with that
well in wwe you have this it's like a
massive soap opera right and i'm a bad
guy i'm a heel
um and so i was a heel when i was in wwe
five years ago
and right now it's just like you know
little vignettes
and kind of making that grandiose
character
that people love to hate
um and it's kind of cool because what
we're doing is we're touching a little
bit on like my real life
on the sense of like what i do on a
day-to-day basis but on the same on the
flip side
we're also throwing in the
wwe sprinkle you know letting the fans
decide
is she coming back and so good guy i
don't i don't know if you're familiar
with wrestling
good guy is called a baby face a bad guy
is called the heel
so right now um the wwe universe one of
the best fan bases in the world
you know they see these vignettes that
have aired the last two weeks and
they're like wait
is even murray coming back as a baby
phase no way so i'm
it's fun to let them play with uh
not knowing exactly where it's gonna
lead up to and go
but um that's definitely
the wwe part you know it's not really
me per se um
doing that so you have to look at that
anything wwe related you have to look at
that as like a character
okay that's interesting yeah i don't
know very much about i don't know very
much about wrestling
i know it has yeah it's i know it's
massive
but it's it's definitely like
a soap opera times a million and then
the physicality that comes with it so
yeah
you know a lot of a lot of smack talking
and a lot of the the
going back and forth leading up to a
match or leading up to and you'll
and you'll see too you'll probably get
confused on some of my posts because
you'll be like wait
what um because i wouldn't talk like
that
norm like myself you know but like
then then i'll jump back into normal me
where it's like okay
so it will kind of confuse anybody
especially if they're not used to the
wwe world
but if you see anything that says wwe
on it or if it is filmed wwe ish
then you know that's the character me oh
that's
fun yeah that's cool it is it is fun
it's really fun i'm having a blast
because a lot of the things that i'm
going to bring this time
is like a lot of stuff that like you
want it
that me personally won't ever say
because it's so like either
arrogant condescending um
full yourself jerk or
just anything often off the cuff i can
say because it's my character
so i can do whatever i want to ruffle as
many feathers as possible
or or do what i want to make people try
to be like yay yes we love her you know
one of the two
okay that sounds very entertaining that
sounds that sounds like fun
okay so you said you said you've been
pretty into reading
so who are your like what are your
favorite books did any stand out
in particular um so
uh it depends on like obviously the
genres right so like
i love jack carr terminalist
and his three um he has a well actually
now four book series
and it's coming out it's super good he
was a uh
he was actually on joe rogan's podcast
joe rogan just out here making like
everybody um you know super known
but yeah he was a navy steel sniper and
then he wrote a great
great books that are really fun and um
they have a little bit of truth even
though you know they're
not supposed to be but um right now
and then obviously your dad's books
amazing um
i like to kind of go all over the place
if i'm looking for something like kind
of fun
and just take my mind away james
patterson the women's murder club i
thought that was like a really great
series right now though my husband has
me reading um
so i just finished bitter fruit they're
on my desk
bitter fruit the guatemalan coo and then
i'm currently reading this guy which
i'm like dude i'm ready for the next one
because
anything that has to do with like
history and like real life
i'm like it takes me a little bit harder
it takes a little bit longer to read
yeah yeah yeah
so this one is uh the new confessions of
an economic hitman
that's what i'm reading right now i'm
almost done though so
i guess my reading to
answer your question it's kind of like
all over the face all over the place
um james patterson is a good one for
anybody that's
just i feel like james patterson is a
good author for anyone
trying to start reading um
because it's like an easy i mean you can
finish a book pretty quick
it's fun it takes you to you know
mystery
and solving solving crimes and stuff um
but then when you really want to get
into like the nuts and bolts depending
on where you're at
um
have you read have you read greg hurwitz
anything by greg hurwitz i haven't no
okay i'll send it to you if you like uh
it's fiction
okay but he does a lot of research into
the characters and
and they're very intense and they're
kind of like um
what are those what's that series matt
damon was in
oh yes um i know uh
okay it's like that or anything like
mission impossible it's kind of like
that it's really exciting but it's also
like intelligently written she's like he
went to harvard so he's smart
um but any of his books are really good
uh greg
hurwitz so you should check him out
that definitely will be something i'll
like for sure because
um i love those types of books you know
yeah yeah um do you have so what are
your goals for the future do you have
kind of a life
plan sketch that you're trying to live
out or are opportunities just arising
and you're like whoa that's amazing i'll
take that one
um no i i mean i think no matter what
i'm always trying to carve the
opportunity to come you know
um even even
navigating as best as i possibly can
i would i would love to do more tv and
film um currently
uh paradise city anybody that
can watch it on amazon prime um just
dropped a month and a half ago
and i would love to hopefully we get a
season two so i would love to do more tv
i would love to do more film um i've
always wanted to do
when i had my hair red something in
marvel you know
something in in that in that world um i
want to also
expand my businesses fitness is huge to
me my dad
um i really believe in like health is
wealth my dad's
been very sick since i was 15. um
he has calling for the not
a million just different things but the
guy i mean italian stallion that phrase
is real
because he is the just
um made a steal like that dude he has
anything that could possibly be wrong he
has it but
um so expanding my my fitness program
through my website um
as well as my my fashion line and things
of that just like really growing the
entrepreneur
in me as well as i think my life sketch
is to have multiple revenue streams
really
um and my goal would be
i would love for my family like to end
up working for like
nem enterprise you know um
that's why i really admire your yours
and your dad's relationship too i love
when you guys do your
like q and a's and stuff on your on your
podcast because
i have a really great relationship with
my dad but um
it's just like it's really cool to see
the
authenticness as well between the two of
you
so i think my my life sketch would be
something along the lines of being able
to
grow my own personal business as well
as somehow intertwine my family where i
could take care of them all
ah that's nice yeah well that's a great
goal like why not if you're going to be
able to
like if you're entrepreneurial enough to
start your own businesses
then why not help out your family and
your friends
for sure i mean i throw that i think it
gives me
the best joy
is because my parents
are like my best friend i get like uh
emotionally even like thinking about it
because they are they
what they have done to provide for
myself and my brothers what they never
had
and the amount of stuff that i've put
them through
um as a as a teenager and in my early
20s like lord knows i could write a book
on the [ __ ] that i
that i that i did put them through the
wringer
but now it's like dude i'm so
appreciative to have such
such parents that were not only such
rocks but my parents are still together
that's unheard of these days
um especially through a lot of the
trials and tribulations that go through
marriage is hard anybody you know it's
something that you
have to consistently work at um
and so you know my parents are my
my uh i guess you would say
they're my drive to succeed and to do
better and to
want to have the revenue streams of
going to go into
the multiple dreams that i have um
so that they can hopefully so that i can
you know
they can reap the benefits not only
seeing the growth
but also um where eventually you know i
can take care of them
yeah well it looks like you're
definitely headed that way or
there so so good luck with that
that's a great dream uh do you have do
you have people you
look up to or people you you try and you
know emulate
in order to grow you know
um
i would have to say
it's really weird because um
i don't really per se
like my parents are my heroes so i look
up to them right um
but then i really i really look up to
your dad
which is just because of like the things
that he puts out there
um without any types like the null
where i get um i love listening to
people that they've done
such research there's like it's not like
they're just off the cuff saying like
a thought it's like no this is actually
um a lot of time and a lot
of research and a lot of reading has
gone into this particular thought
um and you know i really admire
his his books a lot um so
as weird as cool as it is because you're
his daughter which is
not it's not too weird i mean the entire
thing is bizarre
but but no it's nice i'm sure you hear
it a lot
right i'm sure you're just like yeah
yeah yeah it's my dad
great no not at all not at all a lot of
hard work
went into that book like a lot it wasn't
just a casual book
for sure both of them both of them
especially this last one
yeah um so yeah i think
i think i'll leave it at those i i asked
the previous question about like
if if there are people you kind of look
up to and kind of emulate behaviors
because i've been
i've actually asked this a number of
times and it looks to me
like that's more of something men do
because i've been asked that on podcasts
they're like you know
who do you base your behavior off of or
something like that i'm like i don't
really do that
i don't know if that's me being odd
or if it's a man thing because i've
talked to i've talked to
a number of dudes about this and they
say
you know i really like how that man acts
i should be more like him type of thing
and i haven't had that so i was curious
if you'd experience you know why though
i really think that it's like there's
not that woman any women that i look up
to that i'm like yeah you're so dope
you're killing it and i love the way
that you
you present yourself you know
that could that could really be it oh my
god that's harsh
but that could actually that could
actually be the problem it is it is
super harsh and i don't mean it in a
negative way
but i really also feel i
i don't i
like why okay so why your dad is one for
me
is because i like how he handles him not
only because he's intelligent but
i appreciate and i like the way his
mannerism is
when he's getting basically lambasted
and keeping his cool and not emotional
and because i know that like my own self
because i know i refer to it a lot but
anybody of your listeners like a mexican
italian so you immediately
go through like who that is that's
that's this girl
they're like you know and
my first reaction to certain things
especially if somebody is trying
to um kind of like
kind of either dig at me or get me to
react is an
emotional response but watching your dad
in certain heated either interviews
or conversations never once never once
has he
done an emotional thing and i think that
women
in general react
a little too emotional so i don't
off the top of my head i'm not saying
that there isn't any out there
i'm just saying um off the top of my
head i haven't really seen too many
women be able to handle
those types of situations calm cool and
collective
yeah i agree i think it's harder to be
i think it's harder for women to um
because
they're more easily i think we're more
sensitive to threat
just just from being female yeah but we
all want to be liked
yeah you know i think it's it's it's a
really a fine line
because it's always like uh you want to
be liked and you you don't want to be a
[ __ ]
and all this and that or the other so i
think that's kind of where
it kind of also years too
yeah it's interesting to find out though
that you're not necessarily more liked
if you
pretend to be nicer like standing up for
what you believe in
actually makes people like you more than
not
saying anything or pretending to be nice
it's really crazy right because
it is true like if you are if you're
able to like stand your ground depending
on whatever it is
and as long as you are acting in the
sense of like what you truly believe and
you're not trying to play to
what others want you to be like you know
the the
i want to be liked so i'm going to be
this like
proper sweet girl it's perceived
way better when you're just like
spitting out whatever it is that's
coming to your to your mouth
yeah or just this is me i i agree and
it's scary i think you
i think hopefully girls kind of learn
that when they
get older because i was all like i was i
was never that concerned about
talking about things to be honest but
i'm so that was never really one of my
problems but
definitely less of a problem the older i
get like i
care less the older i get which is good
and i think it's working out
uh and you i mean you're obviously the
same way
so i think that that's cool you hit the
nail on the head too though
i think the older that i get the more
i'm like this is how it is like this is
who this is like i'm just
this is where you know um where the
younger me i'm i'm trying to play to too
many things because
i'm so i'm i want that job or i want
this so bad
or i want you to like me so much please
don't take
what i'm saying the wrong way or
something you know what i mean now that
i'm older and plus
um i'm married um and i have an actual
like
career that
insecure little girl is now removed
if that makes sense yeah yeah i know it
totally does
that's definitely a relief yeah
thank you so much for joining me that
was really that was really
interesting that was fun uh if people
want to find you online and don't know
where to look where can they find you
um you can find me on all my social
media instagram twitter facebook youtube
is just my full name natalie eva murray
uh
all together no underscores or anything
like that um
and that's where you'll find me okay
perfect thank you very much for coming
on that was
fun i'm very happy to meet you so happy
to meet you
and thank you so much i had a blast and
really appreciate your time
and also uh having me on
[Music]
you